[Music]
hi I'm rich I work at posit and formerly
art studio and I work on the GT package
have been working on for a while and we
have a great new release 0.8 and today
I'd like to show you what we improved in
terms of like new functions in the
package and also will be improved in
terms of existing functions in the
package we added a bunch of great new
functions to
Target values and do cool things like
replace the values of the things that
were targeted or style the cells and the
other thing is improvements to date and
time formatting especially so I'm really
excited to talk about these new features
let's Dive Right In
um so the first function I want to talk
about is sub underscore values or sub
values
um so it's essentially like a find and
replace so we have a table here I just
made that with the table function from D
plier I'm showing you the table now in
the console and we could look at the
table as it is in GT just by piping it
to the GT function so this is the table
just down here format is HTML so we can
use sub values I'm using it three times
here but I'll show you each time I use
it that we can find and replace values
so in the first case I'm taking I'm
looking for values like 74 or 500 and
replacing with 150. so if I run this
this is going to change very subtly but
you'll see 150 is there now okay if you
do the same thing with finding the
letter b
uh and replacing with the word be that
works it'll just skip over these numeric
columns and go right to the thing that
is the character column and same thing
with 800 you can replace any text so it
could be like any size text uh replacing
the value 800 with the words 800 right
here so that's the values uh you do
quite a bit with it you can even have
like patterns if you know about regex
you'll know what this is essentially it
could be a or C or E if you find any of
those you're going to place the whole
cell with Ace so let's run this
you can see right here that
these values right here are placed with
that replacement value
sweet so we can do more advanced things
use a function that you supply for
instance so this would be like values
that are less than 50.
and the text you're going to replace
those values with is under 50. so let's
just run this and take a look at the
result
there we are lots of values which are
under 50 in this column and also in the
First Column it totally ignores the
column that which doesn't have numerical
values at all which is kind of nice you
don't have to specify which columns it
won't error on you or do weird things
uh so that's the values
um I won't talk about another function
which is new in GTE 0.8 it is tab style
Body
okay so let's start with a initial table
right here this is just like an example
table I mean that I use a lot in GTE for
examples and what we can do now is we
could do a similar sort of thing we can
find values and then style the cells
that have those values so these are
literal values 49.95 and 3333 they exist
over here so let's actually run this and
see what the result is
okay so we got some values which are
colored orange that's because we have
the style here set with this helper
function called cell underscore fill and
the color of orange so we're essentially
filling those targeted cells with that
styling
so we did lots more with this we could
have multiple Styles uh you just enclose
them in a list we can style the text we
could style The Fill of the cells that
we target
we've even style the borders of those so
we're doing the same thing targeting the
same values so if I run this you'll see
that the only thing that changes is in
those two cells The Styling will totally
change
there we go so it's totally different
styling by targeting the same cells with
these literal values so that's time
style Body there's more to it it's kind
of like sub values that I spoke about
earlier and
um you can have different types of
targets
um
you can Target row and Target column
what's that do it just means that if it
finds anything like a cell it'll just
like style the entire row or the entire
column so let's actually take a look at
that so let's do the this whole
statement run it
and you see here that
um because it found 49.95 over here and
we said targets equals row it's going to
style it with cell fill color of light
green all the way across so it's a good
way of highlighting a row uh just based
on
um
just based on the data you have if you
want to highlight a row
um you can do the same thing with um
with this statement right here column so
it found this value it's a little hard
to read but that's 33.33 because we have
charges equals columns we're styling the
entire column so that's what that does
um I'm going to skip ahead here and move
to another new function we have in
ngt 0.8 it's extract cells
so brentas is it allows you to pull out
certain cells from a GT table so you
have a GD table but you just want like a
value from that table and you want to
put it somewhere you can do that with
this function here
so it's actually best shown in a quarter
document I have one open right here
um
so what I'm doing is I'm making a giant
table here
and the key to this is I have a table I
saved it as such like I assigned it to
this object and displaying it but I have
it assigned as an object that's a key
thing here so what you can do in quarto
and in our markdown is you can use
inline R code it's basically this um
backtick with an r and some code inside
there and closing with the backtick
so that's kind of cool because
um we can actually take that GD table
pipe it into extract cells pull out the
cell we want
and the interesting thing about this is
that cell is already fully formatted so
you'll get the same form formatting in
the text of your document
um it's a little hard to imagine that
right now because we just have this
Source document so let's actually render
it I'm going to hit the render button
and then it's going to do its thing in
that background jobs window
and when it's done it should appear as a
preview
um and the key thing is we'll see in
this last paragraph that will have a
value from the table
okay great so I'm going to expand this a
little bit
we've survived so I kept the code in
here the table should be below
great so I pull out a value which is one
of these fractions it's a little bit
hard to format in HTML uh you have to do
you know a little bit of like tag stuff
uh but we don't have to worry about that
because we have extract cells and we
pulled out uh the cell which is from
column F underscore sold and row number
14. and it's right here 2 over 10.
and that's basically this one over here
so kind of nice you didn't have to
replicate that you can use something you
already have inside your document and it
saves a lot of transcription problems in
the future and is you know if this table
changes this changes accordingly uh
which is really cool so that's extract
cells we have another new function
in GT 0.8 and it is
the one called calls align decimal
so this is like an often requested bit
of functionality uh so we have a table
here for instance uh let's see here
let's run this
so we're just generating a table
uh it's a really simple table just for
demonstration purposes
and say we want to format this entire
column of numbers if we want three
decimal places we want drop any trailing
zeros
and that's you know that's pretty much
it for that column so let's actually run
that little bit right there
okay this is great
um the problem is that it's a little
hard to read because the decimals aren't
lined up in a way that you know makes it
easy to say see what is you know before
and after uh the decimal Mark and
there's not always a decimal Mark here
this is like a whole number with no
decimal
um it's a little hard to read you know
it's not impossible but it's not you
know it could be better so that's where
this function comes in calls a line
decimal you just run that
um you can Target a column but you don't
have to it just runs across the entire
table looks for columns that have
numbers formatted it just does the thing
so let's actually run this
great okay so an immediate Improvement
so basically what we have now is we have
the decimal running all the way down
I mean this is like a sort of extreme
example we have n a's and sort of some
wild values here uh but the idea is that
it's a little easier to read
um especially if you you know just have
a ton of these values you just want to
see what the big part is and what the
small part of the number is
uh slots calls a line decimal just
decimal alignment so next is information
about your table
uh you might make a really complex table
like this you know if you're a beginner
with GT you may not know what this is
that's fine that's actually
that's actually just fine so let's run
this let's show the table
so it's a pretty nice looking table
um we have you know roll tables here and
we have column labels across the top and
a spanner that spans across two columns
and some formatted values in the body
so that's great you might get this table
or you might want to style something
like say for instance you know this
column
or some cell in there right
so
um we don't know how to do that because
what you need to do is you have to know
the ID value
um of you know like the column and also
of the row uh so to help that we have
this new function called tab underscore
info or tab info for short
you just pass that your GT table
and what you get is an information table
that shows you uh what your columns are
called in terms of IDs
and then what the labels are so you can
sort of see what you have currently in
your in your viewer in terms of what you
have in your table and you make the
correspondence between that and your
actual like ID which is used for styling
and for things like footnotes so we have
that even the rows might be labeled
differently than
their ID values and it also works for
spanners as well so whatever we have in
your table this will reveal what the ID
values are and this is important because
sometimes
um with certain functions in GT it just
creates IDs for you and you have no idea
what they are so this gives them two so
you can do styling so if you go back to
your other table here we want to style
say for instance this column right here
and you know we didn't know what this
was called for instance we know it's
actually mpgt MPG underscore C from this
table here
right here that's what it appears to be
and that's what it is so now if we run
this we can successfully style that
entire column with a background color of
light blue
because if you just put an MPG like this
we would just get an error
the next function I want to talk about
actually it's a set of functions are
have to do with the date and time
formatting uh features in GT we have a
number of functions format date from a
time from a date time those are going to
completely been overhauled uh Rewritten
totally feature packed now lots more
power than before and we hope it's
actually even easier to use than before
so let's get right to it so let's start
with
a daytime string
um
so we can actually format that with this
other function it's a variant of format
date deck format date so it's great for
examples and it's great for anything
inside
um you know our markdown Corridor if you
just need formatted values like from
vectors and not from Columns of values
in a table it's also good for
demonstration purposes so it has all the
same features it just works on vectors
rather than columns in a table
so if we were to take our date string
um what we can do is we could use a date
style and these are name styles that are
available in this function and also in
this function
it just allows easy access to like
styling um you know an input date time
to whatever output date time so we do
the same thing for uh for many times so
we're just getting the time portion of
this out in this case we're getting 1005
PM because that's what that is here in
the string so it's it's all very
overwhelming like where do we get these
you know there's lots of them we
actually have a function in GT called
info day style we can just run that and
what it does is it gives us a table
of all the different format names that
you can use here in date style and it
gives you an example with an input and
so you can just look down and see what
you know the different outputs are for
the same date
so really kind of cool you just gotta
copy and paste this put into here and
you're off essentially
so same sort of thing for the time
Styles because it's a separate function
it's got a separate function for the
input table right here
great so you see hmp is this right here
and this is the example format of time
so that's all great uh we also have this
other function called format daytime it
has tons of power it allows you to
actually use a formatting string and to
you know style your dates daytime
strings uh just the way you want them
so we can use date Styles and we can use
time Styles together and it'll
separately format those two parts and
give you an output so let's actually see
it in practice
so we get this we get the date and then
we get the time just after that
a cool new thing that was added in um
the latest release is that you can have
locales so say for instance you are you
want a time in a different language so
you can use the same input you just have
to use Locale and then the name of the
Locale and you will get the output date
in that language like basically specific
for that locale
so that's a new thing
um
so another new thing is we have a
totally different way of formatting
dates and times with this new type of
format string you can still use the old
type that hasn't changed but it will
detect whether using this other type
which is called cldr so it basically has
more fields for for my dates and times
it's way more flexible it has tons of
support for time zones as well if you
have that in your input which is totally
supported here but I just want to say
that this is a great way of formatting
really Advanced dates and times so
that's one example here
uh and it's fully localizable so we can
just put the Locale here and it just
switches it to like the Dutch uh version
of that date time
which is really cool
uh so learning about this is actually
kind of difficult it's like uh I don't
see like you need a crash course in this
whole thing
um but
it's no problem because we actually have
documentation and it's really extensive
in the uh in the the
the project website for GT
um and that's available at gt.rco.com
and particularly look at the reference
section and you'll find that the daytime
formatting functions and the
documentation is super huge and there's
tons of help on all this stuff so that's
all I have for the new enhancements and
features in GT
um this is a great script it allows you
to sort of like test out things that are
new and we'll have this script available
uh for everybody to use and the link to
it will be available in the video notes
if you have any questions about GT you
can always ask me in the issues in GT
which is at the GitHub repository for
the package if you want to have a
reference for GT you can go to
gt.rco.com there's a full reference
there lots of Articles and lots of
reference materials for you to learn how
to use the package
[Music]